new video released today along with
details about the suspect in an
officer-involved shooting this incident
occurred monday near clark high school
off valley view in sahara victoria saha
with the update
[Music]
we're now learning the suspect's
two-year-old child was inside the car
the same car that the suspect went in
front of to fire towards officers metro
police were watching the car which they
previously stopped officers say this
time a man and a woman were arguing and
when they walked towards man he started
firing taking cover in front of a car in
that car it was his mother and
two-year-old officers chased him and
then shot and killed the man identified
as demetrius roberts
everyone's tensions are high in those
situations you never know what's going
to happen and it's just an example of
when officers go on a call it's
unexpected what will happen then and
this is a good example of that
metro says officer thuron young's gun
malfunction twice during the incident he
fired 16 rounds total and officer joel
blasko fired three rounds both of these
officers are on paid administrative
leave until they investigate this
incident victoria saha live local now